ces programmes a commencé moi je me suis
dit enfin une nouvelle émission avec des
couples et tout ça pouvait être bien
mais sa part trop trop nous voulons la
téléréalité avec les clash avec des gens
qui ont un niveau un peu basique et
c'est dommage ça ressemble quand même
beaucoup et la télé réalité vous à la
base
j'espère mais à trop les séries tv de
dans le temps vous savez par exemple moi
j'aime les trucs de l'amour là c'était
sur une chaîne sur un bateau l'émissaire
de l'avenir a été moins les gens étaient
s'était déjà rayon produits jeu peut pas
se payer de sa l'éclade alors que
maintenant c'est vraiment un boulot moi
et c'est toujours l'état sauvage les
implants c'est l'attenté jusqu'à la télé
réalité c'est juste qu'ils avaient envie
à la base
bon après parce que on a l'impression
que c'est un attribut officie taux
obligataires atteignant c'est surtout
des gens pas longtemps hostile à il a
tapé jean michel six
michel jour il vous faut des gars est
alors prêt la jeune fille a essayé de
mieux quand même nicolas en lui posant
deux questions et vous allez voir elle
s'attendait pas du tout à cette réponse
si tu étais un événement historique
un événement historique je pense là la
fin de la deuxième guerre mondiale en
ça devait être une belle journée je
savais qu'il était vieux mais de là à
connaître 1945
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on a le stéréotype des garçons machin
bodybuilding et puis les nanas je trouve
ça donne pas une bonne image des jeunes
d'aujourd'hui parce que espérons qu'on
n'est pas tous comme ça en fait